for a city that never sleeps New York
has a lot of dreamers
[Music]
it's so exciting to see you here right
now Katie Keene the pilot is sensational
I think the fans are gonna love it
if for some reason they have not seen
Riverdale can you explain the connection
to them well I am one of the biggest
connections is because Josie has left
Riverdale that is now you know pursuing
her dreams in New York the only other
thing that really kind of makes it a
spinoff is just that it's an extension
of the universe you know you were seeing
in another part of the world where
there's a lot less death where other
Archie characters live so that's kind of
the segue into this new place but it's
nothing like Riverdale you know
everybody's stay in a life for now no
for always when we last saw Josie she
was leaving Riverdale and she was saying
that her dream was to go to New York she
was about to go and go on tour with her
dad yeah where are we when we see Josie
in Katy Keene well she's been on tour
with her dad for a while and you know
we're assuming that she's gotten that
really good taste of what it's like to
be a traveling musician the way that
she's always heard her father was and
hopefully you know a lot stronger in her
own right as a performer and you know
especially if you're doing live
performances and she just kind of had to
leave that safety net and take that leap
and next step in her own career as a
singer-songwriter one of the things that
I think fans are really gonna love is
that Katy keen is a little bit further
in the future than regret yes do you
know how long of a time jump that is um
I just know they're in there like
mid-twenties there's there's a lot of
five years being thrown around I'm not
sure we're just she's not in high school
anymore
so when you see here maybe have a little
romance she's she's a good girl we'll
see that's the thing yes she is a big
girl and thanks to I like to think it's
thanks to the relationship that she had
with Archie you know it was the first
time she was ever truly vulnerable in
that way to let somebody in and to see
her be soft and to see what she's like
when she feels like she fails and is
okay with allowing other people to see
that's
one of the things that I was surprised
to see in the pilot is that katie is
actually an old friend of Veronica Lodge
yeah and Josie of course had that great
relationship with Veronica they sang and
performed together so many times in what
world could we possibly be setting up
that crossover you know I don't know in
in like a perfect world I honestly like
I would love for Veronica to pop up in
New York it would only make sense
considering that she came from New York
to Riverdale and to have her circle back
to her old stomping grounds and to see
you know the woman that she's turning
into and maybe seeing all the cool
little spots that she loved to hang out
and and just you know finding that
dynamic again between the two girls and
then ultimately the three of us I think
we're I'm excited for whoever doe fans
to see is that this is a happy show yeah
it's like it's just it's just like candy
it's not much fun it's you know that's
one of my favorite things about it is
that it has a lightness and hope to it
that is absolutely gone in Riverdale
that's I'd like it's not all the way
gone but it's on its way out like hope
is never anywhere around but you know in
in Cady Keane I also love the fact that
even though it is very bright you know
there's still drama you know there's
still hardship there's still that grit
because it's life
you know life isn't it without it yeah
and it takes place in New York which we
know that Josie can handle yes she can
there's a fun line in the pilot yes yeah
that's that was actually really funny
and I was shocked how funny it ended up
being when we were shooting that scene
and Johnny like cackled doubt and I was
like it's really funny like there's
laughter yes oh my god are we happy the
black hood is nowhere near right but it
was still so amazing to get to see you
perform and still get to see Josie on
our stage what does it mean for you to
be able to evolve as a performer through
this new show you know it was really
touching because you know one of the one
of the moments where you see Josie
singing and I got to watch the pilot
I didn't expect it to be as moving as it
was especially being a New Yorker myself
and going in and out of the city all the
time and seeing people seeing on the
subways and on the streets and wanting
to join in but like not wanting to like
steal the spotlight or anything but you
know it it was really it was really
something to watch to people who don't
know each other and are from complete to
completely different worlds connect
through this one medium of music and
have it be so beautiful and attract
other people to it it was like it was
like a warm little lights like a little
fire in the darkness I wasn't expecting
to be so touched by something that I've
done for three years now that it's still
hard for me and to see it on screen and
to feel that you know I've really kind
of found that that space where I can
shine and Josie can too it's it's
something this show is all about young
people struggling to reach their dreams
and I feel like everyone's gonna be able
to relate to that was there ever a
moment in your own career when you're
like I don't think I can do this anymore
yes there were a couple and my it wasn't
even so much that I couldn't do it
anymore it was that I couldn't sustain
myself on the path that I was on even
though I knew I couldn't deviate from
acting as a career altogether I was
gonna have to change the planet a bit
and I wasn't ready to make that change
but I was struggling and then I ended up
booking Riverdale and that changed it
and there's still so many lessons that
I'm learning now at this point in my
career because it's still so young and
you know kind of in its infancy a bit so
I'm learning as I go but I've definitely
have though I've had those moments I
love that Katie Keane is such a
fashion-forward show yeah Katie
of course it wants to be a fashion
designer she's so great she has almost
great clothes how do you think we're
gonna see Josie style evolve
I don't know I feel like she's I mean
she's exactly she does have a great
style and it is elevated a bit and I
know that she's always gonna take that
extra
of advice from somebody who's in the
know whether it's from Katy or even from
pepper because pepper very much so is an
it girl you know I think it'll be fun
I'm just excited to be on set with a
bunch of like rolls of fabric cuz I used
to sew when I was young and just this I
just I'm gonna they're gonna find me
like wrapped up in the fabric on set and
just pulling it to see which way the
stretch is and just anything fashion and
clothes and making it's gonna be so much
fun
I'm just so excited cuz you know that
I've always wanted Josie to have more
time to show and when we first met her
on Riverdale she was that it girl she
had this rush she came through and she
was just like Archie don't even think
you can try and join my group
she had that sad and so we're gonna get
to kind of see her with these other
quote-unquote it girls yeah and and kind
of like see what this is gonna be like
what does that mean for you to be able
to play this out you know it's great
because it's nice to be in an
environment where there are people who
are striving for the same thing you know
and we can all support each other and
even though we're from different
backgrounds we also understand that
struggle of wanting to succeed in our
career in a city that sometimes is so
hard to just be in and so having that
safety net especially at home is is
gonna be really nice definitely yeah
have you been able to keep in touch with
anyone from Riverdale yeah uh you know
as much as I can you know everybody's
always so busy but you know I'll text
I'll FaceTime you know I'll send little
videos here and there just to you know
send out the little love even if it's
just like a gif of me throwing hearts
you know that's in anything that I can
do to just you know keep them in my
space well and you were so close with
Casey I know he goes to New York quite a
bit yeah that's definitely a crossover I
would like to see happen I would love I
would love for Casey to come to New York
and you know to have Kevin get bitten by
that Broadway bug because it would be so
perfect yeah definitely yeah we're not
gonna be saying goodbye to you on River
no just yet we will be seeing you in the
season four premiere yes which is going
to be a tribute to the lake blue Perry
and also his on-screen character Fred
Andrews yeah
what did that mean for you to come back
for that episode and what can you share
about that episode um well I was really
thankful to be a part of it you know I
had I really wanted to I didn't know
when it was gonna happen but I
definitely let it be known that however
possible you know I wanted to pay my own
respects as well it was tough it was
really tough it was a really hard
episode and you know it was kind of a
grieving process for all of us and
especially for me so you're you're gonna
see that you're gonna feel that when you
watch the episode it is gonna be very
tearful and touching and heart-wrenching
but you know it's necessary and I I feel
like we've done him and his character
justice and I just hope that everyone
sees that receives it the same way you
know especially his family and and
everyone else who knew him who had the
pleasure of meeting him